so spooky action at a distance was
Einsteins kind of appellation for the
idea of nonlocality nonlocality is that
more technical term for it so the
example I often give is two coins so you
can treat some of these particles as
having two possible outcomes of a
measurement and you can think of that as
heads or tails of a coin so you create
two of them you give one to your friend
your friend goes off somewhere and you
other and you both flip the coin and if
you come up with heads they come up with
heads you come up with tails they come
up with tails heads tails it just goes
back and forth and yet they're the same
answer on both sides so this non-local
connection among these particles or
whatever kind of object is bearing that
connection seems to violate our
intuition from Einstein's theory of
relativity so that theory among other
things said that influences in nature
are limited by the speed of light so you
can't have any kind of subspace radial
or ansible like they have in science
fiction there has to be a limit to the
speed at which influences and signals
can propagate so these these particles
which can exist on opposite sides of the
universe seem to disobey that principle
but the situation is kind of subtle and
the reason that subtle is that the
particles are unable to send an ordinary
communication you can't use them to
radio signal or have some kind of
telemetry or remote control across that
gap and the reason is quite simple the
reasons that the the outcomes of those
particle experiments or the flips of the
coin are random so they just come up
heads or tails and heads or tails and
you can't decide is it heads or is it
tails so you've got no way to manipulate
the coin and thereby produce an outcome
at the distant location so you can't
communicate you can't send a signal so
on the one hand the phenomena seems to
violate relativity theory but on the
other hand it kind of pulls back from
the precipice it doesn't actually
violate it in a practical sense you
can't send a signal faster than light
it's still however poses kind of a
theoretical conundrum
why are these particles able to
coordinate their behavior even though
they're so far apart so there's a
tension with onon son's theory of
relativity not perhaps an outright
observed contradiction of the theory the
question of why these particles can
coordinate why these coins can land on
the same side no matter where they might
be has really been very perplexing and
it Einstein was troubled by it he
thought the particles for instance were
basically had a mechanism in them or
some kind of like gimmick built into
them like a magician would have kind of
a trick coin and he thought the
particles were also like trick coins
that they were pre-programmed to land on
one side or the other but in the 60s and
70s that particular explanation was
ruled out so the other possibility is
that there might be some kind of signal
going between them but that seems to be
ruled out because you can do the
experiment kind of in synchrony you can
do it at the same time and yet the coins
can still act in court in a coordinated
way so you're kind of left with like
what's going on it's just a mystery here
there's almost like a magical magic wand
or obi-wan sensing the destruction of
Alderaan kind of situation going on here
it's kind of a magical situation so the
thinking today is that it represents a
violation or a kind of undermining of
space the very fabric of space that
things in the universe seem to be
located far apart from one another they
have individual locations and they need
to interact by mechanisms that propagate
within space and these particles violate
that expectation so it seems to indicate
that space itself is somehow not
fundamental it's not a real or deep
feature of reality